liam but i don't even know their [ __ ]
names yeah it's about i think they're
cute as [ __ ] who was the related guy you
fought that was 300 pounds shane cowan
you fought shane cohen yeah but what he
had one arm and i had two arms but i was
playing and he wasn't
so i started playing around with it at
one point i had his good arm caught and
i went ha ha look at that i could punch
her as much as i wanted to right now but
obviously we're playing and then he
punched me in the back of the head and
made my face go all numb and tingly and
i looked back at him i was like what are
you [ __ ] doing dude and his face was
bright red and he just threw like
haymakers until he knocked me out oh
[ __ ]
are you guys in talking terms though now
well he told me many like about a couple
years ago that let's see it live his
trainer told me told him before he came
out that
uh jason just got you here to knock you
out and be famous on youtube so he's
come to make you look stupid and shane
got convinced that that's what i was
trying to do so he got serious oh my god
see i'm not even hitting him huh this is
what white people looked like before
they were evolved
[Laughter]
that's when we first got really cold
we are pissed
too shaky so where is it
shane's huge
yeah my corner was scared for me nobody
was everybody was worried because he's
actually really good as well on top of
yeah didn't he famously go back oh
my god that's the first time look at him
he stood over me like he wasn't happy he
looked angry about it and i was like
[ __ ]
this is not what i've i thought we were
gonna just
yeah well i was gonna get hurt but not
you weren't gonna be serious that looks
like a big crowd dude how many people
are there uh like 3 000 killing the game
yeah i sold out the joint for like 10
years
whoa bragger what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's information we didn't need to
know good point no i love you dude
congrats see that's another aspect of
your life you're doing so many [ __ ]
[ __ ] in your life yeah you've traveled
the world
i'm just i could say that about myself i
know we should be [ __ ] in
pure joy he knows everybody he's like
from this era of like the legends of
comedy where he was like in there he
knows all the [ __ ] that we wish we knew
what do you want to know baby oh richard
pryor stuff yeah big dick what else bro
you're sorry i never said such a weird
thing
i didn't know everything
i carried him once you know um he got
sick later in his life and when i was a
kid before i got mad tv
um me and my friend freddie had to carry
him a couple time on stage that's
the amount of interaction i had with him
did he know
that's that's huge though they're pretty
cool that's huge yeah i remember being
in the back door i say this sometimes
but um
and george carlin
would come in and he would always go to
me
mr lee and he would just walk by he
wouldn't talk but he always knew my i'm
about to cr i don't want to cry but like
he always knew my name
i was [ __ ] sick that was [ __ ] dope
as a kid that's awesome you're going
what the [ __ ] that's [ __ ] dope you
referred to you as mister yeah mr yeah
because the first time he ever did it he
goes hi i'm george which and i got bobby
lee and then every year he would just
always remember
you know what i mean that's called class
buddy yeah
yeah i feel like you have a little bit
of that i'm really bad with names
yeah he wouldn't say mr lee
i would say hey
my good friend
yeah let me hey man
yeah yeah let me stop with the jokes
buddy what are some of the things that
you would say either you know how they
have chief
yeah yeah you know what i say cap i go
what's up captain is that a good one is
that insulting yeah no
what whatever you i cheat i say mate and
because you you all think that's all